[Music]
we're here with visual effects
supervisor Stefan's already and we're
going to talk about Marvel Studios
ant-man and the wasp this I I have a
feeling is pretty much visual effects
pretty much I mean except or I was so
this is the scene where Hank finally
dives towards the quantum realm and on
the way it stops at that level which we
call the tardigrade level I don't know
if you remember the first film but in
the first film we had some of these
animals kind of floating by the camera
and and Oh Peyton always liked them and
he wanted to bring them back into the
film but feature them a little bit more
these things are categorized and the
very interesting thing is that most of
the time when you see them because they
are very small they're always
photographs with an electronic
microscope so they always look solid
they always look like very opaque opaque
and but the truth is they are not opaque
they're really they're are super
transparent actually they when you
photograph them with a real camera and
not just an electronic microscope
they're really beautiful and transparent
and translucent we want it to be optical
you know just talking with Bates and we
wanted it to look real and optical so we
did a lot of work of research and now
they look like how they move so we had
to do a very high detail model of it and
they are they're huge that that's the
funny thing is that they're super tiny
but we're smaller and Hank is smaller
than they are so they become this
gigantic like quails we shot Michael in
the pot there we are adding the bubble
around it so we get all the reflections
from the environment and we add
interactive light you know we knew the
light would be pretty strong there so do
those panels sort of push the light they
push animated lights so that we we can
play with the light and we knew that
there would be light and shadow and all
these things so we we always kind of put
a little bit of interactive light on our
actors with this kind of scene so that
we can really have something rich in the
end in the inter compositing so do you
shoot this first actually yeah we should
we should this first we had a previous
we knew all the angles that we needed to
have we could show it to Michael you
would know roughly where
to look at what would happen around him
and then we do we showed the element we
do what we call a post which this is
supposed to be so we're using the
element that we've shot and we're
starting to lay out all the different
animation elements that we're going to
have in the shop and then we start you
know doing all that research on how
things look and how the light works and
the amount of atmosphere and all the the
optical kind of quality that we want to
do to the shot and we start compositing
and rendering everything and putting
them together pickup Marvel Studios a
man on the wasp on digital now as well
as blu-ray and 4k Ultra HD October 16th
[Music]